so last week we had this hearing where
Donald Trump's Supreme Court nominee
Brett Kavanaugh and his first of many
sexual assault accusers Christine Blasi
Ford were questioned by senators sort've
Christine Blasi Ford was actually
questioned by a sexual assault
prosecutor and then was also asked some
questions by Democratic senators
Kavanagh was questioned mostly by
Democratic senators a couple Republican
senators allowed the sex assault
prosecutor to ask him questions and then
with absolutely no explanation
whatsoever after a couple of Republican
senators had delegated their time to
these two the prosecutor she disappeared
and then it was just glowing remarks and
really tough questions like do you swear
to god you didn't sexually assault a
woman were what we saw from Republican
senators Christine Blasi Ford was calm
and direct and clear Brett Kavanaugh was
erratic unhinged out-of-control yelling
ignant indignant but also contradictory
up Kavanagh was boxed into corners
figuratively metaphorically multiple
times about whether he had blacked out
from drinking alcohol but since senators
had only five minutes with him the clock
kept running out as for example senator
Cory Booker made significant headway to
pointing out that the guy's clearly a
liar as senator Blumenthal from
Connecticut made headway and started to
expose Cavanaugh's lies on the matter
and then Republican Senator Lindsey
Graham shows up with the completely
out-of-this-world rant about these
hearings being the most unfair thing
he's ever seen done in politics ever
including to a Supreme Court nominee
which of course borne no connection
whatsoever to the real world into the
facts on the ground but most importantly
Christine Blasi Ford answered questions
and Brett Kavanaugh avoided answering
questions Vox actually has an
interesting graphic which were showing
our television audience where they
visually show blue for answers and red
for non answers as you can see here the
top graph is Brett Kavanaugh a lot of
red a lot of non-answer
and then Christine Blasi Ford answering
every question that was asked for her
when it comes to questions about
investigations Christine Blasi Ford said
yes time and again that she supports an
FBI investigation into her claims
Cavanaugh played coy saying things like
I will do what the committee wants and
that an FBI investigation won't show
anything definitive anyway but still not
saying yeah do an FBI investigation yeah
and at one point dick durbin asked
Kavanagh but personally do you want an
FBI investigation
I mean I'd imagine if you're falsely
accused on this this is tough on you and
you want to exonerate yourself yeah and
he just paused for 5-10 seconds he
didn't have an answer to that one and I
think he repeated one of his other
things like the four witnesses in the
room said it didn't happen or one of
these other things that he kept going
back to so let's think for a moment if
Christine Blasi Ford had comported
herself like Brett Kavanaugh did she
would have been called and out of
control
not credible hysterical woman on the
basis of her behavior after the hearings
we heard that Republican Jeff Flake big
hero is calling for a delay to
Cavanaugh's confirmation vote so that
there can actually be an investigation
it seemed as though wow Jeff Flake
standing up here doing the right thing
Republican senator Lisa Murkowski saying
she supports the delay for this
investigation
senators Jeff Flake and Chris Coons who
called for the investigation saying in
an interview last night that if any
lying is uncovered by Brett Kavanaugh in
this investigation that that's it that's
it for his nomination and that this
matters and that it's really important
that this is done that's all great
unfortunately the investigation is and
may always have have meant to have been
meant to be a total sham controlled by
the White House the FBI has a week to do
this so-called investigation they're not
allowed to investigate the claims of one
of the accusers Julie sweat Nick Trump
is claiming that the FBI can do
absolutely whatever it wants he tweeted
the other day NBC news incorrectly
reported as usual that I was limiting
the FBI and
of Judge Cavanaugh and witnesses only to
certain people actually I want them to
interview whoever they deem appropriate
at their discretion please correct your
reporting except White House officials
are confirming that certain limits have
been placed here and even when it comes
to investigating the claims of Christine
Blasi Ford and Deborah Ramirez forget
for a second about the third accuser
Julie sweat Nick the White House did
according to multiple reports provide a
list of witnesses that the FBI is
allowed to interview which makes it
completely impossible to actually do a
full investigation and follow the leads
where they take you we also learned that
mark judges girlfriend who has knowledge
of Cavanaugh's friend mark judge
participating in exactly the type of
alcohol and drug riddled gang rape
situations that are at issue here
she tried going to the FBI and she was
completely stonewalled so what we have
here still is a situation that is meant
to do what in the end it's meant to push
Cavanaugh through it is meant to push
Cavanaugh through and at this point I
wouldn't even put it past Republicans to
have sort of tacitly gone along with
Jeff Jeff flakes requests because they
knew that it was going to be staged as
part of the plan from day one the FBI
will come back and more than likely
since the scope of the investigation is
limited they'll say well based on what
we were able to look into here's what
the witnesses said period and Senators
will say all right we did the hearings
we heard from Christine Blasi Ford we
did an investigation let's vote and he
becomes the next Supreme Court justice I
don't hope that happens but I do still
think it's the most likely scenario I
suppose you could chalk this up as a
tiny win for Democrats getting that one
week investigation especially cuz they
don't have any power and you know they
want something much broader but this is
kind of what they could settle for but
you're right I mean it's probably gonna
come back inconclusive this happened
30-plus years ago they'll ask some
questions but ultimately I think he'll
be pushed through the one alternative
would be that even if the specific
credibility of any particular claim
can't be adjudicated that they come back
and say the guy did lie during the
earrings and that would be another story
and we'll talk about that in a moment
but to talk about Kavanagh this is a man
who's fundamentally at the base level
unfit to be on the Supreme Court
regardless of the sexual assault right
and then you remember oh wait he's been
accused of sexual assault by at least
three women that we know about
specifically so far so this is a sham
it in dangers the future of the United
States as we know it and aside from the
allegations and the unhinge rants
Cavanagh many times about small things
throughout the hearings lied Bernie
wants a perjury in VEX investigation and
that's exactly what I want to talk about
next